okay welcome to EE 380 spring a computer
systems the Stanford computer systems
lab claw Club spring 2019 2020 the year
of the kovat I'm Andy Freeman and the
other course organizer is Dennis Alice
most museums are paintings
other visual arts like dance plays etc
have their own little of their own
display medias and
so most museums end up being paintings
with museums I always liked or
technology artifacts cars coal mines
submarines now you know the museum I'm
talking about trains tractors I grew up
in a farming community where there was
actually a tractor museum but the most
important technological artifacts in the
last 50 years are computers however
computers visually tend to be fairly
boring outside of 1970s and 80s movies
and the other problem of the computers
is that their tools and their owners
once they don't they cease to be useful
to their owners they just discard them
they don't pass them down to other
owners of need less or are willing to
pay as much and there's no collectors so
they essentially disappear or yeah they
just basically disappear which makes
collecting them into museums which is a
very good way of educating future people
getting people interested is incredibly
hard today's speaker lunch such htech
has solved that problem so without
further ado
you're on great well thank you Andy I am
Lynn szostak and I'm the chairman of the
board of the Computer History Museum and
if you haven't been there you should
take a visit to it because it's just
down the street it's over on shoreline
and 101 now of course right now we are
closed because of the pandemic but we're
hoping that pretty soon we will open up
again let me give you 30 seconds of my
background so you can understand how I
came to this Odyssey
I was born and brought up in New York I
went to the Polytechnic Institute of
Brooklyn got a masters and bachelors in
physics Polytechnic by the way is now in
WIU's engineering school and then in
1970 I changed everything about my life
went to Stanford changed my field of
study and enrolled as a graduate student
in the relatively new computer science
department which then was a graduate
only department and was part of the
humanities and Sciences division of the
school not the engineering school
eventually had a great time at Stanford
and at SLAC escaped with the PhD went to
Carnegie Mellon was on the faculty there
currently computer science for a little
while came back to Silicon Valley and
out of a period of 16 years did two
different startups both in the
networking field and one of them the
second one was a relatively successful
so I decided to retire let me retire and
go back to my first job which was
teaching so this time at Stanford I
started teaching none of this background
qualifies me to start a museum of any
sort yet it happened here's what
happened
if you look at the Stanford online
calendar catalog you will see a course
listed as EE 282 computer systems
architecture it's basically the
fundamentals of designing computers many
of you have taken it or will taken it
will take it it talks about architecture
and instruction sets processor
technology memories i/o system software
virtualization and so forth I happen to
be very familiar with this course
because I took it fifty years ago when I
first got to Stanford in 1970-71 I don't
remember which quarter and then I was
taught by legendary professor of EE
Edward McCluskey famous for all sorts of
techniques for designing computers
including something you probably don't
learn about anymore the Quine McCluskey
minimization algorithm but it's still at
the bottom of their log and VHDL is the
way they compiled what you design and I
level language into detail gate designs
so I remembered this course and in fact
25 years after I took it
it was the course that I taught in the
winter quarter of 1994 now these three
different versions of the same course
separated by 25 years had some things in
common at very many implementation
details that were different and the
focuses were different when I taught
heard it was designing microprocessors
when Ed McCluskey taught it to us it was
the design of mini computers and when
it's being taught now notice that it
says notebooks smartphones and data
centers that's fine the fundamentals are
still the same and you are all learning
how to design computers when I taught it
it was with the beta test version of the
Hennessy and Patterson classic now
classic textbook computer architecture a
quantitative approach
compared to what I talked 25 years
earlier there was one important
difference most of the history had been
erased when ad McCluskey taught us about
for example virtual memory in paging
systems he distributed to us the
original papers from Tom Kilburn and
others at the University of Manchester
describing the Atlas computer which at
the time was the most powerful computer
in the world
it was a transistorized computer with a
whopping 16,000 48 bit memory the words
of memory could add 500,000 ads a second
and it was the first machine that had
virtual memory I thought it was a
fascinating way to learn technology to
understand where it came from
so one of the things I started doing was
to spend the first five minutes in a
kind of Show and Tell moment bringing in
old artifacts like this this is a piece
of genome dolls PhD thesis at the
University of Wisconsin he was a PhD in
physics but he decided that he wanted to
design a computer and he did it was
called the whisk and this is a piece of
his computer built out of vacuum tubes
which some of you may not know ever
existed or what they do this module is
probably one flip-flop so this is one
bit of information
I found that the students were
interested at least in five minute
sections in history and I decided as a
result of that that something needed to
be done to introduce history I wasn't
going to change the curriculum at
Stanford so I thought my contribution to
this problem would be to start a museum
look we ought to learn about the history
of our field if you're physicists you
learn about Newton and Einstein if
you're a chemist you learn about Lavoie
ZN boyle if you're a biology major you
learn about Mendel and Darwin why don't
computing science computer science and
electrical engineering students learn
about how our earth and von Neumann and
Eckert people who created our field so
my crazy idea was to start a museum
there were several advantages one is
we've all had the problem of having
people come to Silicon Valley and say
show it to me show me Silicon Valley and
why don't you show them you drive around
and you can see s fold parking lots and
concrete tilt-up buildings how come if
we're the center of the world for
computing that there isn't an computer
museum in Silicon Valley so I decided I
would start it was a totally nutso idea
I knew nothing about starting or running
a museum but I started writing white
papers this was the first one from
October of 1995 I started shopping the
concept around I tried to get people
interested in in the idea and many were
and I realized quickly that the
important thing was not about collecting
artifacts and he talked about the
difficulty of collecting objects that's
true but a museum is not a repository of
objects it's a repository of stories so
I want to take a little brief detour now
and talk about an example story of the
kind that I wanted to preserve and
present and we do preserve and present
in the computer museum we eventually
built
it's actually the most embarrassing
question that people ask us who invented
the computer
everybody knows who invented the
aeroplane and the phonograph and the
light bulb how come you don't know who
invented the computer no you asked some
young folks and they'll say well maybe
it was Steve Jobs or Steve Wozniak or
Bill Gates of course none of that is
true the problem is it's a difficult
question to answer it's a complicated
story but if you put me up against a
wall and say you have to choose one
inventor of the computer who is it
that's my answer
this handsome general and Charles
Babbage he was the son of a wealthy
banker living in London he didn't have
to work for a living he became the
location professor of physics at
Cambridge University which was the
position that Isaac Newton had had and
he spent his time thinking about things
one of the things he did in doing his
mathematics was to compare all of the
different texts that gave mathematical
functions in those days if he wanted to
find out a sine or a cosine or a
logarithm you didn't compute it that was
very tedious you looked it up in a book
where it had been pre computed and he
compared all of these books and they all
differed on at least every page there
were some differences and obviously one
or the other or both of them were wrong
at one point he said I wish to god these
calculations had been executed by steam
which was a metaphor he meant it was
some way to do it mechanically with
precision and accuracy so that you know
the results would be correct and he
devoted the rest of his life to
designing machines that would do things
like that to precisely calculate
mathematical functions there was an easy
way to do science cosines and logarithms
you can approximate them with a higher
order polynomial equation you can use
the method of differences once you start
with the first few values of computing
subsequent values so here's an example
this is a second-order polynomial
equation the second difference is
constant so the way to compute the next
value of the function for
X equal 40 is just to do two additions
easy so Babbage decided he would build a
machine to do this a calculator the
technology available to him at the time
was not electronics
it was mechanics so he designed
something he called the difference
engine he began in 1823 to calculate by
the method of differences sixth order
polynomials using 16 digit numbers this
was not an analogue computer this was a
decimal digital calculator that little
wheel down there is an example of how he
stores one digit
it's a rotating brass wheel that can be
in one of ten positions indicating what
the value of that number is it also in
his design had a complicated printing
mechanism because he didn't want the
result to have to be manually
transcribed and typeset because that
introduces the possibility for errors so
he designed this machine now how did he
do it you know nowadays when we designed
machines we use CAD computer-aided
design
well Babbage had his own kind of CAD it
was cardboard aided design these are
original pieces from Charles Babbage of
cardboard mock-ups showing the kinds of
parts he needed to build in order to
create his machine so he designed it he
went out for funding to build it he got
funding from the only venture capitalist
of the day which was Queen Victoria who
gave him seventeen thousand pounds
that's about two million dollars worth
of money today and said go build it
what happened he spent that 17,000
pounds ran out of the money it took him
19 years he built about half of the
parts the 25,000 parts that his machine
would have needed and he got into fights
with his craftsmen he wasn't good at
managing people so the result was a
total collapse of the project and his
calculator was never built now one of
the reasons was that his eye was not on
the ball anymore while he was building
this he had a better idea for something
else he wanted to build this happens to
engineers all the time instead of
finishing the project they're working on
now they want to work on version 2 or
some Better Project and Babbage's Better
Project was a computer he called it the
analytical engine this is a top-down
view of the engine he would have built
each one of those circles is a tall
column of those digit wheels like we saw
before so this would have been a huge
machine the size of a locomotive all
mechanical no electronics powered by a
steam engine it was a computer that we
would recognize today it had a separate
CPU which he called the mill it had
memory which he called the store it had
pipelining so that you could have
multiple instructions in progress at the
same time that parallel processing so
you could do multiple things at a time
that conditional branches so you could
decide what to do based on the result of
a prior calculations it had loops it had
micro code so that you could encode
complicated things with one instructions
and he had invented things that we
reinvented 150 years later like carry
look-ahead sophisticated math algorithms
it was an amazing machine it also of
course had software you had to program
it he did not put the software in memory
instead he put the software on punched
cards these were cards that he had seen
used since the beginning of the 1800s by
jacquard on looms to automate the
weaving process and he had the idea of
using those cards to
encode the instructions that his
computer would follow well how do you
make a loop you connect one end of the
cards to the other end of the cards into
a big loop and then it repeats over and
over again the same set of sequences now
this was a great design which Babbage
did not publish he worked alone and had
no collaborators he only had one
collaborator an unlikely one it was this
woman Ada Lovelace she was the daughter
of the poet Lord Byron estranged from
his wife and Eva's mother decided that
in order to keep her from going crazy
like her poet father she would be
tutored in mathematics and she took
correspondence courses from famous
mathematicians of the day like Augustus
de Morgan famous form de Morgan's laws
now this was extremely unusual for a
woman to be involved in science in the
1800's but she did it she was brilliant
she worked on the programming if you
will of Babbage's analytical engine now
she wasn't really the world's first
programmer Babbage had never yet
designed the instruction sets what she
did were things like this with Babbage
this is an execution trace of the
program that would run on the analytical
engine to compute Bernoulli numbers so
it would be easy to imagine what the
program would have to be to create that
sequence of operations she published
when Babbage did not translate her to an
Italian description of Babbage's machine
and and worked with Babbage on the
refinement of the machine in order to
support these kinds of calculations that
image was entirely focused on
mathematical computation one of the
things that Ada Lovelace saw was that it
could be used for more than that at some
point she said it might act upon other
things beside number the engine might
pose elaborate and scientific pieces of
music she even foreshadowed AI at one
point she said it does not appear to me
that cerebral manner needs to be more
unmanageable to mathematics than side
aerial and planetary matter I hope to
bequeath to generations a calculus of
the nervous system she wanted to
understand how the analytical engine
could be used to create intelligence
none of this ever happened because
Babbage never even attempted to build
his analytical engine
so was Babbage a nut did he designed
machines that could never have worked
well 150 years later the London Science
Museum found 20 pristine drawings in the
archive done by Babbage of a machine
that he designed after the analytical
engine
it was a simplified version of his
original Difference Engine and this
fellow Doron Swade curator of computing
at the London Science Museum decided to
see if Babbage was a nut or was he a
brilliant engineer he took Babbage's
original drawings
worked for 17 years to build 8,000
pieces of iron bronze and steel using
exactly the same manufacturing
techniques that Babbage could have used
built the machine 11 feet long 7 feet
high waists 9,000 pounds this cost
several million dollars about the same
as Babbage burned through 150 years
earlier
and this is the result
the thing on the right is the microcode
if you will it's the cam stack that
controls the machine the crank on the
side is what powers it there are 31
digit decimal numbers in stacks along
those vertical columns and the thing to
the left is the printing machine that
automatically creates a printing plate
in quartz
perfect
you
the London Science Museum actually built
two of these machines we had one of them
on display at the Computer History
Museum for eight years until it went
back to its owner who had paid the
several million dollars to have it built
now why did Babbage fail clearly his
Difference Engine built exactly the way
he designed it works perfectly
maybe his analytical engine would have
worked had he built it there's a project
now to investigate whether we could
build it had that happened we would have
had computers a hundred years earlier
than we did we would have had a computer
in 1848 instead of 1948 so why did
Babbage fail it wasn't for lack of
brilliant engineering there are many
reasons one of which is he didn't know
how to organize the project and run the
company this is sound familiar
there are probably 25 companies within
20 miles of Stanford which are who are
going to fail because they have
brilliant engineering and don't know how
to manage the project create
now Babbage almost had someone who would
do that
Ada Lovelace wrote to Babbage in 1843
saying if I am delay before you in the
course of a year or two explicit and
honorable propositions for executing
your engine would they be any chance of
allowing myself to conduct the business
for you she's basically offering to be
the CEO of his company
and he turned her down who knows why
maybe he you know they didn't trust the
idea of a woman doing it I think it was
in large part because Babbage was
bullheaded and wouldn't have accepted
anyone in that position in any case
Babbage died a bitter and disappointed
old man nothing he had ever designed was
a success he said at one point another
age must be the judge of my talent and
we judge his talent in engineering a
plus in management F I said none of his
inventions had ever succeeded there was
only one it was this it was the
cowcatcher
the thing in front of a locomotive that
pushes cattle off the track but that's
not the legacy he wanted to live delete
to us so I think this story is a great
story and these are the kinds of stories
that I wanted the museum to be able to
tell so I was going to go off and create
a museum first thing I did is to look
around for other examples so I traveled
the US and the world looking for
examples of computer museums I found
great examples of technology museums you
know in Chicago the London Science
Museum the deutsches museum I figured
surely there must be some if you look at
how many other Technology museums there
are there are thousands of railroad
museums an automobile museum some
aviation museums and I discovered there
were no computer museums this is a
picture of all the computer museums
before 1980
there was only one exception and that
was a museum that Gordon Bell had
started in Boston now Gordon Bell was a
legendary is a legendary computer
architect he was a head of engineering
and Digital Equipment Corporation for
many years responsible for them bb8
pdp-11 the backs and so forth and so on
he wrote a great book called computing
structures readings and examples which
reprints many of the papers about his
fear of computers and he decided he
wanted to see somebody collect all of
those computers that was fact one fact
two is the machine on the lower right is
whirlwind it was a legendary machine
built at MIT they discarded it Gordon
called up the Smithsonian saying this is
a national international treasure it
needs to be preserved and the
Smithsonian said we don't collect
computers so Gordon said I'm gonna have
to start a museum of my own so inside a
Digital Equipment Corporation in 1979 he
started a computer museum
at a museum store and exhibits had
problem getting funding Digital thanks
to Gordon was paying for it but
obviously if it was called the digital
computer museum which meant Digital
Equipment Corporation they couldn't get
anyone else to finance it so they moved
they moved to the wharf in Boston right
next to the Children's Museum in front
of the big milk bottle
they created a computer museum that ran
from 1984 in 1999 they had exhibits this
is a diorama showing the UNIVAC one
computer they had programs this is a
list of the programs going on in 1982 I
think it was they started the Fellows
Awards giving honor honors to important
pioneers that's grace Murray hopper who
received the first such award in 1983
but the problem was that in by the 1980s
much of the computer industry had left
master so it was in Silicon Valley they
had a hard time getting funding they
began to morph into a Kids Museum which
was a fine thing they had a big
walkthrough computer where kids climbed
over giant replicas of personal
computers but it wasn't the history
museum that Gordon wanted to start and
they were in trouble it was clear that
they weren't going to survive all of the
good stuff most of the good stuff was no
longer on display it was in the back
room in Gwynn Bell wardens wife who ran
the museum would give you a private tour
I said okay that's sad so I returned to
Silicon Valley kept planning learned the
lessons from Boston computer museum I
thought and then I got a call from
Gordon Bell who said I have a deal for
you
don't start your own Museum restart what
we tried to do in Boston join the board
of the Boston computer museum to start a
West Coast outpost which reinvigorates
the original history mission and that's
what we did in the winter of 1997 now my
first objective was to preserve the
artifacts they were one-of-a-kind things
that could no longer be collected again
I managed to finagle some free space
from a friend who was running a
Technology Center at Moffett Field under
the aegis of Ames NASA Ames he's a world
war two vintage Quonset huts with leaky
roofs notice the sandbags in front of
the doors on the right right in the
shadow of the big dirigible hangar that
still had its skin on in those days and
we commissioned seven huge tractor
trailers to move the artifacts out of
Boston to California
it didn't quite have the authority to do
that but I figured possession was
nine-tenths of the law
I wanted these things to be preserved so
we moved them sometimes a little hokey
we didn't have a forklift that could
drop down this piece of the sage so we
backed two trucks uh back back to each
other and lowered the tailgates in
synchronization so that we could get the
machine down to the ground it was an
amateur effort to be sure we even moved
objects into the dirigible hangar I
managed to get a forklift license and
move some of the stuff around I think
I'm the only computer science PhD in the
world with a forklift license at least
as far as I know we started colouring
and inventory increate adalah exhibit
called visible storage where basically
we set up all of the equipment or the
stuff that was interesting looking and
let people tour around it had not a lot
of labels it was just stuff it was great
for the cognoscenti people who knew what
they were looking at loved it it wasn't
the museum I was dreaming a building but
it was a step in the right direction we
got some press this is an article in the
San Francisco Examiner about our efforts
to build the museum so one of the
questions is where to build it
I had some conversations with folks at
Stanford which we're handle izing my
Keller who I think is still there ahead
of the library said why don't you build
it on Stanford campus on the opposite
side of palm drive from the Cantor Arts
Museum so we would have arts on one side
and Technology on the other side it's
the location where the being Performance
Center is now I thought that was a great
idea so I talked to the chairman of the
board of this Stanford trustees and he
said great idea if you've got 20 or 30
years to make that happen
go for it I didn't
try number two was at NASA Ames at
Moffett Field NASA was going to develop
a research park this is their conceptual
plan of the research park the in in red
it's circled computer museum they were
going to give us three acres right in
front of the big dirigible hangar to
build our museum was going to be a land
lease from the government they were
inside the hangar going to create a
California Air and Space Museum sounded
like a tantalizing prospect we get an
architectural competition we had bone
core models built over the building we
were going to create
it was great fun we were headed into the
trap that many museums fall into of
putting our emphasis on building a
building instead of building a museum
well there were three things that
happened that saved us from that trap
one is of course that the blossom Museum
closed so we were now free to do
whatever we wanted we were our own
California corporation the second is we
realized pretty quickly that NASA moves
with the speed of a federal bureaucracy
and we were startup people we wanted to
move more quickly than their research
part which 25 years ago they had that
wonderful land for is still in progress
and maybe someday we'll build it the
third thing that happened in about 1999
2000 was the dot-com bust up until that
time there were no buildings available
in Silicon Valley they were all full and
suddenly there were lots of see-through
buildings buildings that had been
abandoned and were available
like this one this at the corner of
shoreline in 101 was the sales and
marketing headquarters of Silicon
Graphics famous computer company at the
time
founded by Stanford professor Jim Clark
and it was empty so what can graphics
had sold it to a developer and I fell in
love with it I took one look at it and
said this is a museum they built it as a
museum only they didn't know it at the
time it was filled with 300 purple
cubicles for Silicon Graphics so I
wanted to buy it you
the problem is it costs 25 million
dollars that we didn't have so I went to
our board and said I want to borrow 25
million dollars it was a crazy notion
because many of the people on our board
had been on the board of the Boston
computer museum where they had failed
raising less than a million dollars to
retire their mortgage and here it is I
was asking with no support for the
notion that we could ever pay it off to
borrow 25 million dollars well now they
let me do it it turns out in retrospect
to have been a brilliant move
accidentally brilliant that 25 million
dollar property now is probably worth
about two hundred and fifty million
dollars and we own it we don't have to
pay rent to anyone so we moved yet again
now we had decent forklifts this is the
Kray to being moved off the truck into
the shoreline building we created
version 2 of visible storage again a lot
of computers without a lot of labels we
didn't have the money to build exhibits
yet but we did other things too we had
all this great space we had lots of
volunteers we started restoring old
computers upper left is an IBM 1620
upper right is the first computer from
Digital Equipment Corporation pdp-1
lower left is the an IBM 1401
installation with two running 1401 s and
lower right is the world's first hard
disk the Rama designed in 1955 by IBM at
their San Jose Research Center
with the exception of the 1620 on the
upper left all three of these are still
running and we operate them and
demonstrate them to the public
all the time here's an example of a
crowd watching the 1401 system being
demonstrated we also demonstrated really
old computers like this
Babbage difference engine that I
described earlier we cranked it every
day it worked perfectly
we were often running even though we
didn't have permanent exhibits we
reinstituted the fellow awards that had
started with Grace Hopper in Boston this
is the 2008 film awards with Gene Bartok
who was one of the original ENIAC
programmers and Bob Metcalfe and Linus
Torvalds so sure you know those names
one of the things we started with high
priority is to do video histories
videotaped oral histories of computer
pioneers we're losing them at an
incredible rate if you don't get them on
tape now they're going to be lost
forever
nobody ever interviewed Alan Turing
there is no video of Alan Turing so by
now we've done about a thousand oral
histories they're all long videotaped
multiple hours this is one from Paul
Walker you may not know that name but he
was the fellow who wrote the Das disk
operating system for the Apple 2 the one
on the bottom is John Backus a few years
before he died he was the inventor
implementer of Fortran one of the first
high-level computer languages we started
writing blogs we started releasing
collecting and releasing source code so
the blog on the left describes the
release of Apple to das source code
source code is the literature of
computing and if we don't preserve it
we've lost a lot of our history we did
public programs we did interim exhibits
waiting to be able to raise the big
bucks for doing our permanent exhibit we
posted lots of videos online both new
videos like the presentation that Paul
Baron inventor of packet-switching
did for us and historic films like
univac all of these films are up online
if you go to youtube.com slash Computer
History you can see them all we
instituted educational programs
educational programs were about I would
say 20% history 80% new tech but it is a
way to experiment with the idea of
inspiring kids with a combination of
what's happening now and what happened
in the past
we eventually ran out of space in our
building and knew that we were about to
what I wanted to create a big permanent
exhibit so we bought it another building
over in the East Bay where real estate
is a little bit cheaper we bought a
25,000 square foot warehouse for storing
all of the stuff that's not on display
like every Museum what you can put on
display is a small fraction of your
collection and if you want a really cool
experience talk to me sometime we'll be
getting a private tour of our warehouse
PS
we'd finally raise the money to be able
to build our first new permanent
exhibition so it's called revolution the
first 2,000 years of computing it's a
big exhibit it covers everything from
pre computing calculation to the
Internet and the World Wide Web
this is the mini computer gallery it's
designed for not just the geek but for
the general public who's interested in
where computers came from everybody
these days is a computer user it's
pretty high marks it's big it's got 19
galleries 1,500 objects 5,000 images 16
films four theaters it's been a great
success we opened it in 2011 in 2015 we
want them to do more exhibits we were
running out of space again so we bought
our third building this one is a 50,000
square foot building in the East Bay for
the archive which is paper software
video that's where we do scanning of
documents and films and photographs
it's where researchers come to visit to
use the archive it's where we recover
old software moving stuff into that
building gave us the opportunity to take
its space in the main building and
create a software exhibit this is a very
different kind of exhibit than anything
we've done before it's
it has history in it has technology in
it but it says much about the social
impact of the technology and where it
might be going as the history it's a
it's a case study kind of exhibit so
it's an experiment in doing different
kinds of exhibits for different
audiences so brief summary of the museum
in numbers this is of course before
covered 19 we are like all museums in
the world
closed but we were getting 130,000
exhibit visitors a year probably as many
who came for events both hours and
rental events we now have a hundred and
forty-four thousands probably now after
150 thousand objects in our collection
got 75 employees who are still being
paid even though they're working from
home and 200 volunteers and we raised a
bunch of money to make this work we are
of course struggling in this period when
we're closed like all museums but we
have a pretty good chance of surviving
we have assets we have a 30 million
dollar endowment we started this museum
with the idea that we are creating an
institution that will live in perpetuity
and I don't know whether we've done that
or not I'll know somebody will know 50
or 100 years from now I won't be here to
know but hopefully it will happen and I
should point out that after 25 years I
decided to step down as chairman of the
board and new administration will be
taking over and I think the museum will
be in good hands from moving into the
future
it's been an amazing journey but
remember as our exhibits designer
Kirsten - I've taught me a museum is not
about objects it's about stories so I
want to end with another story that we
that we tell in the museum and I think
is important for people to know it's
about the memory that made computers
work
by the end of the 1940s everybody knew
how to build computers john von neumann
had described
maybe not invented but had described
that the right way to do it was to have
enough memory city so that you could
store the program in memory as well as
the data the question for the engineers
is what do you build that memory out of
here are some of the examples of things
that early computers used to store
memory on the top left is a rotating
magnetic drum
it's mechanical so it's slow it's also
relatively unreliable on the lower left
is a mercury delay line that's the main
memory for the UNIVAC one computer it's
18 tubes of mercury with a speaker
basically at one end and a microphone at
the other end and you induced standing
waves in the tube of mercury and you
could encode a thousand bits of
information stored that get recirculated
around so this is one thousand 18 bit
words that was the entire main memory of
the UNIVAC one computer expensive
unreliable if you stamped your foot next
to it as it was running it would disturb
the standing waves in the mercury and
induce errors in the middle as the
Whitlam Williams killed burned tube
which is basically a TV screen old
cathode ray tube where you would paint
dots on the screen and the thing that's
folded down would be folded up which is
a screen that would detect when a spot
on the screen was illuminated whether
there was a dot there before so it was a
destructive readout system but it was
entirely mechanical you could store a
thousand bits on the face of the screen
it ran at electronic speeds and it was
the memory that was used for the first
machine that ran a stored-program it was
June 21st 1948 at the University of
Manchester the machine called the baby
it was a 17 line program the first piece
of software ever to run inside memory
the thing on the right was a very
complicated device designed by RCA which
was basically a plasma tube where you
would store on plasma bits of
information very expensive they barely
ever got it to work it was the memory
that was initially stored on the johniac
computer now notice that three out of
the four of these is all except for this
electron
I have the property that you're not
building any specific thing for a bit
that seemed like a good idea it seemed
too tedious to have to build something
specifically for each bit you depended
rather on a bulk analog property of
magnetic materials or an electrostatic
screen or traveling waves in a tube of
mercury
none of these were the things that made
computers work but what made them work
was a return to that original idea of
building something for every bit
it was magnetic core memory it was one
of the things that
I brought in as a show until I this is
the third world's first magnetic core
memory
it's from the world one computer this is
a core plane that has 1,000 bits you put
16 of these core planes together you get
1k 16-bit words and that's the way all
computers worked for the next 25 years
let me be sure my screen here
so how does corner memory work well it's
based on an old principle of hysteresis
that dates back to the late 1800s
basically certain magnetic materials
like a ferrite ring have the property
that as you increase the electric
current which is to say the strength of
the magnetic field pretty much nothing
happens for a while until suddenly it
snaps and the magnetism changes from one
direction to the other and then you can
do things in the other direction and you
continually change the saturation
nothing much happened and then suddenly
it steps into the other direction and by
the way once it's snapped it records
that information forever because it
never gets demagnetized unless you put a
magnetic field on it that core plane I
just showed you might have encoding of a
program for the whirlwind that's 65 or
70 years old okay so how do you address
this memory and how do you create a
practical memory out of it you can't
afford to put wires through every core
that are individual well there are two
clever ideas one is because of the way
hysteresis works you can put half of a
con through a core and nothing happens
so you can have one wire that goes
through in the x-direction multiple
cores one wire that goes through the
y-direction through multiple cores
nothing happens and only one core will
switch because it gets current from both
wires gets over the threshold for the
hysteresis curve and the magnetism will
switch so how do you know that it's
switched well the switching magnetic
field induces an electrical current
you put a sense wire through all of
those cores and then you can sense when
the addressed core has changed
magnetization so that's the principle on
which a single core plane works this is
a sixth this is one bit of a 16-bit
memory main memory for a computer its
destructive readout notice so that once
you've read out the core if it was a one
it is now a one if it was a zero it's
not a one
so whatever you've done when you read it
you have to rewrite clever idea cores
got smaller and smaller it was used for
all computers from then until 1972 or
three when Intel came out with the first
semiconductor memory
okay so great invention who invented it
it's a similarly complicated story to
the inventor of the computer
here's one person who contributed and
this is a delicious story because
Frederic may was a sidewalk and Street
inspector in Los Angeles and he
moonlighted in his kitchen laboratory on
magnetic materials and how he might use
them for electrical purposes in 1947 he
patented something called a memory
transformer it was basically a
transformer that would remember its
prior state and it worked and when IBM
got around to wanting to use magnetic
core memory they purchased the patent
the rights to that patent from baiii in
1956 well that wasn't the only invention
on wang from harvard and later from wang
labs in 1949 patented the idea of
destructive readout that patent ii was
purchased by IBM IBM knew that this was
the way to build computers another
interesting story by the way is that IBM
was very late into the computer business
but once they got into it they came in
with both feet and dominated the
industry relatively quickly by adopting
new technology like core memory
third fellow Yann Reichman from RCA he
was actually the guy who had invented
this electron but he also worked later
on core memories in a 1950 patented the
notion of coincident current IBM lisent
that patent as well
contributor number four Jay Forrester
from MIT in 1951 patented something
that's very much like reichman's patent
not exactly the same coincident current
IBM needed that patent as well but IBM
was unwilling to license it what they
said was that we will license you for a
royalty of two cents procore that was
anathema to Tom Watson he refused it he
went to court to try to invalidate their
patent on the basis of reichman's patent
and that court fight went on for years
eventually IBM lost they had to license
that patent in 1964 from MIT for
thirteen million dollars which was the
largest patent sellin settlement and
technology at the time
it was a traumatic event for the
computer industry because it made
engineers realized that the technology
they use and the patents that exist on
them are extremely important it was also
frustrating to people like Jay Forrester
I love this quote he said it took us
about seven years to convince them that
was a good idea in the next seven years
in the patent course that convinced them
that they had all not thought of at
first success as a thousand father's but
failure isn't often so if you have a
successful idea you better be prepared
to protect it Jenny Forrester was our
second fellow of the computer Museum in
1995 and he died relatively recently
the computer of that world that that
Forrester worked at at MIT was called
the whirlwind computer and it was
coincidentally the computer that Gordon
Bell wanted the Smithsonian to collect
and since they refused he decided to
start a computer museum so in some ways
the core memory story and the whirlwind
story are all linked together in history
of the museum it is still a work in
progress one of the projects were
working on now is reading the old world
wind tapes we have about a hundred and
fifty of these medical magnetic tapes
that were recorded on whirlwind that
haven't been read for 50 60 years
something like that
we are beginning to read them now
I developed a software based recovery
system for data from magnetic tapes we
basically digitize the analog signals
coming off the head of the tape and then
in software reconstruct the bits the
original data and the software that was
running on these machines many many
years ago if you're interested by the
way all of my software is up on github
then you can take a look at it at the
link
so it's been an amazing Odyssey lots of
lessons to be learned one about history
when I was a kid a student I wasn't that
interested in history but I've obviously
gotten really interested in history now
it can be inspiring you can learn from
it David Kennedy in the history
department at Stanford said it's an
imperfect but indispensable guide to the
future look if all you know about is the
present that's a single point you can
draw any straight lines of the future
through it at any angle if you
understand history at least you have
some other points you can do some curve
fitting you can do some prediction about
what is likely in the future you can
learn about what things were tried and
failed the other lesson for me was don't
be afraid to do something new and
unusual hey knew nothing about museums
and I was able to succeed that road
always happened so you have to be
prepared to fail but it was a great
Odyssey and I encourage you all to to be
bold and try things that you don't know
how to do and might fail it that's all
it's a little disconcerting to be doing
this without a live audience oh I can't
get any questions but if you have any
questions feel free to email me the
email address is there of course visit
the computer museum and our website
computer history org there's lots of
material there lots of historic material
visit the YouTube channel where we have
thousands and thousands of videos up
there come visit once we open again if
you're interested in more of my thoughts
on the history of the museum I have a
couple of links there two papers I've
written so
enjoy history enjoy the future thank you